it's the end of an era that dates back
to the post-civil war reconstruction
tomorrow night on New York's Long Island
Ringling Brothers and Barnum and Bailey
Circus will perform its final show after
146 years on the road ringmaster
Jonathan Lee Iverson we rolled it in
coca-cola rolled and in Major League
Baseball
we are the bedrock of American pop
culture we've added to the vernacular
throw you hat in the ring the show must
go on
hold your horses all those things it's
something that is really irreplaceable
the greatest show on earth
as it's known ran into trouble when
animal rights activists accused the
circus of mistreating its iconic
elephants under pressure Ringling
Brothers retired the elephant's a year
ago but with operating costs rising and
ticket sales falling the circuses parent
company decided in January to pack up
the tents for good they really did
become like a family between us and the
audience seeing them crying because they
speaking of probably that is gonna be
the last time they're gonna see us and
and the show the end of the circus means
about 500 employees including acrobats
animal trainers and clowns will be
looking for work but for now as they say
the show must go on
[Applause]
I remember my first trip to the circus I
remember those peanuts I remember the
Tigers and the elephants no long I
remember the lights we used to twirl in
Madison Square Garden I loved that
moment everybody has a circus memory we
sure having said that the fact that
there's some acrobats out of work you
know maybe we could use a few on the
show
suggestion it's already a circus